ils ne sont pas venus pour philosopher
mais pour enfants se faire entendre en
ce jour symbolique
ces profs de dijon beaune ou encore au
sol devaient pour la plupart surveiller
les épreuves aujourd'hui mais exaspéré
par ce qu'il voit comme une absence de
réponse du ministre à leurs inquiétudes
ils se sont mis en grève si les
établissements avaient anticipé en
réquisitionnant beaucoup plus de
personnel pour surveiller l'examen
l'image interpelle on est ici pour nos
élèves
l'ebit sont nés ici en grève aujourd'hui
on sait c'est vraiment un geste
exceptionnel ça arrive et trois fois
depuis depuis les 60 dernières années
que des épreuves sont en grève le jour
du bac c'est parce que en fait le
ministre a refusé toute négociation tout
dialogue écoles des services publics
après avoir manifesté devant leur lycée
ils se sont rejoints devant le rectorat
dans leur viseur la refonte de
l'enseignement au lycée et cette réforme
du bac inégalitaire selon lui nous on
veut un bac nationale avec des épreuves
nationales qu'ils soient les mêmes qui
rendent le bac équitable et qui lui
donne une valeur quoi sinon si je sais
dans chaque lycée chaque hall il s'est
fait son bac maison ça n'aura plus de
valeur ça va complètement
dévaloriser battre au rire jean michel
blanc car leur a répondu ce matin que
les querelles devait s'arrêter aux
portes du bac mais la grève pourrait
être reconduite demain et certains
évoquent une grève pour la correction
des copies
[Musique]